let's make some damn good beef chow mein  first we're gonna make the sauce later  you're gonna feel like it's not enough  sauce but it is enough sauce pour it  over the thinly sliced ribeye and make  sure it's all evenly coated now we gotta  make the veggies these guys are  important they add a lightness to the  dish and bring lots of different  textures to the dish now the meat i  don't cook the meat and veggies together  because the balance of flavors are nicer  when cooked separately sorry i somehow  didn't film adding the noodles but these  are taiwanese oil noodles they're  amazing great bouncy texture highly  recommends anyway thinly sliced ribeye  is so freaking good in charmaine it's  tender it hugs the noodles and sometimes  the veggies will get caught in the meat  pockets so every bite is just perfect it  is so  effing good  yum